BRIT BRET WE GOT IT IN.
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JAMES
COMEY IN AN INTERVIEW HERE
ON "SPECIAL REPORT."
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL
CATHERINE HERRIDGE FOX NEWS
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE
CORRESPONDENT.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY SENIOR
EDITOR AT THE FEDERAL LIST.
MARLA LIASSON "NATIONAL
PUBLIC RADIO" AND JOE
DIGENOVA FORMER U.S.
ATTORNEY.
CATHERINE, FIRST TO YOU, YOU
HAVE COVERED THIS FOR A LONG
TIME.
WHAT STUCK OUT WITH YOU.
>> THE AMAZING EXCHANGE TO
ME IS WHEN YOU HAD DIRECTOR
COMEY CONFIRM THAT HE SHARED
THOSE MEMOS DOCUMENTING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PRESIDENT WITH THREE OTHER
PEOPLE SO THE COLUMBIA
PROFESSOR, THAT'S WHAT HE
TESTIFIED TO ALSO WHAT HE
DESCRIBED AS HIS PERSONAL
ATTORNEY PATRICK FITZGERALD
AND THEN THIS OTHER
ATTORNEY.
WHAT'S KEY HERE IS THAT HE
TOLD YOU, BRET, THAT THOSE
MEMOS WERE RETURNED TO THE
FBI AFTER THEY FOUND
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
HE CAN CALL IT WHATEVER HE
WANTS.
THAT IS A CLASSIFIED SPILL
OF INFORMATION.
DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER THEY
HAVE CLEARANCES.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE ABILITY
TO SECURE THAT INFORMATION.
>> Bret: JOE?
>> I WAS AMAZED -- I THOUGHT
IT WAS BREATH-TAKING
DUPLICITY.
AMERICA'S DIRTY COP
CONTINUES TO AMAZE ME WITH
THE DESTRUCTION OF THE
INSTITUTION THAT HE USED TO
LEAD.
AND WHAT CATHERINE HAS JUST
SAID IS STUNNING.
IT'S NOT HIS DECISION.
HE'S SUPPOSED TO KNOW WHAT'S
CLASSIFIED.
HE HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
CLASSIFY UNDER THE LAW.
AND, YET, HE MAINTAINS THAT
HE DID NOT GIVE AWAY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
HE LEAKED CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION TO THE "NEW YORK
TIMES."
THAT'S A CRIME.
>> Bret: MARA?
>> I THINK THAT THE
DIFFICULTY THAT COMEY IS
HAVING IS THAT HE IS NOW IN
A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT ROLE.
AND HE CAN'T BE IN TWO ROLES
AT THE SAME TIME.
THE COMPLETELY IMPARTIAL LAW
MAN WHO BELIEVES IN SERVING
THE PRESIDENCY AND THE
INSTITUTIONS AND NOW A
PARTISAN ACTOR.
AND THAT'S, I THINK, WHERE
THERE IS A LOT OF CONFLICT.
>> Bret: MOLLIE?
>> I THOUGHT HIS MOST
INTERESTING ANSWER IS WHEN
YOU ASKED HIM IF HE WOULD
STILL BE AT THE FBI IF HE
HADN'T BEEN FIRED.
HE SAID HE WOULD BE AND
BECAUSE HE BELIEVED HIS JOB
WAS TO PROTECT THE FBI.
I THINK THAT'S A VERY
TELLING STATEMENT THAT
SUGGESTS THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING OTHER THAN JUSTICE
THAT WAS HIS HIGH CONCERN
AND WHEN YOU WERE ASKING HIM
ABOUT WHY HE DIDN'T REVEAL
INFORMATION TO THE PRESIDENT
ABOUT WHO FUNDED THE
DOSSIER, HE SEEMED TO BE
SHOCKINGLY UNINFORMED ABOUT
WHO FUNDED THE DOSSIER.
HE DID NOT -- HE, IN FACT,
ATTEMPTED TO DENY.
>> Bret: I WANT TO PLAY THE
SOUND BITE BECAUSE I WAS
PREPARED TO GO DOWN A
DIFFERENT ROAD AND THEN HE
SAID HE DIDN'T KNOW.
>> WHEN DID YOU LEARN THAT
THE DNC AND HILLARY CLINTON
CAMPAIGN HAD FUNDED
CHRISTOPHER STEELE'S WORK?
>> YEAH, I STILL DON'T KNOW
THAT FOR A FACT.
I KNEW IT WAS FUNDED FIRST
BY REPUBLICANS.
>> Bret: BUT THAT'S NOT
TRUE.
>> I'M SORRY?
>> Bret: THAT'S NOT TRUE THE
DOSSIER THAT CHRISTOPHER
STEELE WORKED ON WAS FUNDED
BY REPUBLICANS.
>> MY UNDERSTANDING THE
ACTIVITY WAS BEGUN THAT
STEELE WAS HIRED TO LOOK
INTO WAS FIRST FUNDED BY
REPUBLICANS AND THEN PICKED
UP -- IMPORTANT THING WAS
PICKED UP BY DEMOCRATS
OPPOSED TO DONALD TRUMP.
>> Bret: CATHERINE?
>> ONE OF THE BASICS OF
JOURNALISM AND ANY
INVESTIGATION IS
UNDERSTANDING THE
CREDIBILITY OF THE SOURCE
AND THE FACT THAT HE DIDN'T
HAVE HIS ARMS AROUND WHAT
THE SOURCE WAS FROM THE
DOSSIER WAS REALLY KIND OF
CONFUSING TO ME.
AND THEN, JUST AS A FINAL
POINT, WHEN YOU ASKED HIM
ABOUT THAT BEING THE BASIS.
>> Bret: FOR THE FIGHT